the world's press from a makeshift
platform constructed in one of kiev's
metro stations
he said one of his priorities was the
evacuation of people caught up in the
siege of mariupol but that it was
difficult to trust the russians
we offered any format for the exchange
of our people who are currently in this
predicament in this terrible situation
in this bloody encirclement
he warned that he would break off talks
with russia if the remaining ukrainian
troops in mariupol's as of style steel
plant were killed
if our men are killed in marry a pole
and if these pseudo referendums are
organized in the south then ukraine will
withdraw from any negotiation process
twice the president posed to make way
for a passing train
we hear from president zielenski
on a daily basis but this is the first
large press conference since the
beginning of the war and it's happening
70 meters on the ground and one of the
metro stations of cave and actually when
the capital was under threat you had
hundreds of people here
seeking shelter
the president appeared relaxed he says
he was grateful for the kind of weapons
his country was receiving of late from
the united states and western allies but
reminded people that without additional
weapons there would be no fight
i do not consider the option that our
partners will not give us the weapons
they promised i do not consider this
option at all they have no alternatives
we will not provide them with this
opportunity we have no other chance to
win back our land
but zielinski also wondered about the
upcoming visit of u.n secretary general
antonio guterres who is visiting moscow
before coming to kiev
i think it's a mistake to visit russia
first then ukraine this is simply wrong
for what to hand over a message from
russia
asked by al jazeera if he wanted to
pursue people for war crimes
i don't care whether it's in the hague
or somewhere in ukraine what matters is
how many will be imprisoned and for how
long
another strong performance from the
ukrainian president in a remarkable
setting a president dealing smoothly and
efficiently with the international media
but also president zielinski the realist
as ukraine faced more military actions
saturday including a missile strike on
an apartment block in odessa that killed
a three-month-old baby
al jazeera kevin